[Music]
on December 7th 1941 16 year-old Akiko
dosa shared in the horror of millions of
Americans
when Japanese planes attacked Pearl
Harbor what she did not know was how
that shared experience would soon leave
her family and over 120,000 Japanese
Americans alienated from their country
both socially and physically as of 1941
Japanese American communities had been
growing in the US for over 50 years
about one third of them were immigrants
many of whom settled on the west coast
and had lived there for decades the rest
were born as American citizens like aki
born Akiko Katayama he grew up in a
diverse neighborhood where she never
thought of herself as anything but
American until the day after the attack
when a teacher told her you people
bombed Pearl Harbor
amid racism paranoia and fears of
sabotage people labeled
japanese-americans as potential traitors
FBI agents began to search homes
confiscate belongings and detain
community leaders without trial
Aki's family was not immediately
subjected to these extreme measures but
on February 19 1942 President Roosevelt
issued executive order 9066 the order
authorized the removal of any suspected
enemies including anyone of even partial
Japanese heritage from designated
military areas at first
japanese-americans were pushed to leave
restricted areas and migrate inland but
as the government froze their bank
accounts and imposed local restrictions
such as curfews many were unable to
leave Rocky's family among them in March
a proclamation forbid japanese-americans
from changing their residency trapping
them in military zones in May the army
moved Aki and her family along with over
7,000 japanese-americans living in
Seattle to camp harmony in Puyallup
Washington this was one of several
makeshift detention centers
former fairgrounds and racetracks where
entire families were packed into poorly
converted stables and barracks over the
ensuing months the army moved
japanese-americans into long-term camps
in desolate areas of the west and south
moving Aki and her family to Meaney Doka
in southern Idaho guarded by armed
soldiers many of these camps were still
being constructed
when incarcerated in these hastily built
prisons were overcrowded and unsanitary
people frequently fell ill and were
unable to receive proper medical care
the War Relocation Authority relied on
incarcerate the camp's running many
worked in camp facilities or taught in
poorly equipped classrooms while others
raised crops and animals some
japanese-americans rebel organizing
labor strikes and even rioting but many
more like aki's parents endured they
constantly sought to recreate some
semblance of life outside the camp's but
the reality of their situation was
unavoidable like many younger
incarcerate okie was determined to leave
her camp she finished her final year of
high school at Minidoka and with the aid
of an anti-racist Quaker organization
she was able to enroll at friends
University in Kansas for Aki's family
however things wouldn't begin to change
until late 1944 a landmark Supreme Court
case ruled that continued detention of
American citizens without charges was
unconstitutional in the fall of 1945 the
war ended and the camp's goes down
remaining in cars were given a mere
twenty five dollars and a train ticket
to their pre-war address but many no
longer had a home for job to return to
Aki's family had been able to keep their
apartment and Aki eventually returned to
Seattle after college however post-war
prejudice made finding work difficult in
Carson EES faced discrimination and
resentment from workers and tenants who
replaced them
fortunately japanese-americans weren't
alone in the fight against racial
discrimination Aki found work with one
of Seattle's first interracial labor
unions and joined the Congress of racial
equality she became a teacher and over
the next several decades her advocacy
for multicultural socially conscious
education would impact thousands of
students however many X incarcerate
particularly members of older
generations were unable to rebuild their
lives after the war children of
incarcerate
alling for the United States to atone
for this historic injustice in 1988 the
US government officially apologized for
the wartime incarceration admitting it
was the catastrophic result of racism
hysteria and failed political leadership
three years after this apology Akiko
Doce was awarded the Human Rights Award
from the Seattle chapter of the United
Nations celebrating her vision of peace
and respect for people of all
backgrounds for a heart-wrenching look
at how internment affected one family in
particular check out this video on the
hakuna brothers United by blood / war
[Music]